joined now by the travel correspondent
of the independent that's simon calder's
travel editor of course for giving me
there simon um
talk to me in more detail about what on
earth is going on with british airways
and i'm guessing with other airlines as
well
well british airways by far the biggest
carrier at uh london heath rowe has
announced or well they told the trade
first their agents and uh holiday
companies and so on they said right we
are going to be taking out yet more
flights this winter now you'll recall
that um at the start of the summer
season that was the end of march all the
airlines had great plans for the summer
for example easyjet said it was going to
have its biggest ever program from
gatwick that soon fell apart and they uh
have cancelled thousands of flights
british airways which was getting back
to pre-covered levels at heathrow has so
far cancelled about 30 000 flights um
there's another 1250
uh just been announced in the next uh
couple of months which will take us to
the end of the summer season
and then in the winter the pressure
should be off cancelling 10 000 short
haul domestic and
european flights and uh that represents
um along with the uh
flights which are being taken out long
haul as well fewer of those a few
hundred of those represents about two
million seats taken out of the market
now you might think well that's great
for the environment and um undoubtedly
it is but if you're a terror if you're a
passenger it could be bad news
yeah absolutely so what can you do what
are your rights
well if you're affected and and the
whole idea by of making these
cancellations now
is that um actually many of the flights
won't have that many people booked on
them um it's very straightforward you
could get a refund but of course the
vast majority of people are actually
going to want to travel where they want
to go when they want to get there
and therefore british airways will put
you on one of its other flights and um
in general most of the cuts are going to
be on routes where there are more than
one flight a day so they can just switch
you to another flight
if for some reason there isn't another
ba flight available then they have to
put you on a different airline um but
the impact is going to be felt
disproportionately
i fear okay on the domestic route so
that's from belfast city from aberdeen
in vanessa glasgow edinburgh newcastle
and manchester
those are flights which typically have
lots of people connecting and i was just
taking a look at what the cuts mean so a
month today going from london heathrow
to aberdeen where you'd normally expect
six or eight flights a day from first
thing in the morning till uh last thing
at night there are just two they're both
in the evening and the lowest price at
this stage is 215 pounds whereas
normally you'd expect to be able to pick
something up for less than half that and
it's people in the regions of the uk who
i think are going to be most affected
and you could find that yeah you've got
a connecting flight from heath row but
you're actually going to be hanging
around for many hours because the flight
you were on has been pruned
up yeah what about if you're flying long
haul are those less likely to be
impacted
yeah i mean that's where british airways
makes the vast majority of its money and
they will always protect the long-haul
schedule there have been some cuts so
for example there's multiple flights
every day to new york and certainly on
some quiet days they will they will fill
it a few of those um and that probably
won't mean more than an hour or two
difference between what you were
planning to do important to say that at
this stage doesn't look like anybody's
going to be getting any cash
compensation because they are aiming to
give at least two weeks notice of these
changes which means they are not liable
to pay out
any compensation
for the inconvenience
but honestly the amount of capacity
that's being taken out means that
anybody who is looking to travel will
find that there is less choice
and that uh prices are higher both on
british airways itself and of course on
the competitors easyjet and ryanair are
picking up bookings all over the place
because british airways um uh is culling
so many flights but ba itself isn't
losing out that much because overall
price levels are going through the roof
uh to get here to italy i pay 300 pounds
which is roughly three times what i
would have liked to have paid oh well at
least you're in italy enjoy it while you
can it's good to talk to you thank you